poissy pourrait faire partie des futurs
cité éducative
un programme qui vise à impliquer
l'intégralité des acteurs locaux dans
l'accompagnement éducatif des enfants
la ministre de la ville nadia est était
en visite dans la commune yvelinoise
pour étudier le projet les acteurs se
mettent ensemble se mettent autour d'une
table et réfléchissent à une méthode de
travail a aussi les divers
accompagnements que qui peuvent
mutualiser proposé pour servir le
parcours de l'enfant dans le cadre de sa
réussite scolaire
aujourd'hui déjà 80 cité éducative ont
été labellisés en france ce qui
représente 520 mille enfants accompagnés
les 12 17 ans doivent être les premiers
bénéficiaires de ce programme l'école le
sport la culture les parents avec 7
cette épine dorsale que pour présenter
d'éducation nationale peut être pour
nous un élément facilitateur qui n'a
d'autre objectif que de bien vivre
ensemble
outre l'éducation nationale le but est
d'aider des initiatives locales déjà
existantes comme ici à la fabrique
numérique du fab lab qui a un objectif
simple est de former des jeunes donc 17
29 ans qui sont en échec scolaire
souvent déscolarisés qui n'ont pas le
bac voilà pour essayer de susciter a une
vocation ou de les aider avec les outils
qu'on a sur place une formation plus
poussée ou un emploi dernier axe du
projet cité éducative la sécurité un
comité de prévention de la délinquance
s'est tenue dans la journée autour de la
table les acteurs locaux ont présenté
leurs idées pour lutter contre la
délinquance en travaillant avec les
associations travaillant avec les
services de police
les collectivités la collectivité locale
et ses élus l'éducation nationale et
donc ses commandes tout le monde se
mobilise pour lutter efficacement contre
la délinquance
six poids s'ils venaient à bénéficier de
cette aide la ville toucherait 450000
euros de l'état pour la mise en place de
ce projet